viele nachwuchs magier tausende von
nachwuchs magiern haben zu ihm hoch
geschaut und wollten es auch so schaffen
wie die beiden wie siegfried und roy 2
die den durchbruch geschafft haben sind
die ehrlich brothers und wir freuen uns
wirklich sehr dass die beiden uns jetzt
zugeschaltet sind hallo guten abend
schön dass ihr dabei seid
wir haben noch vor kurzem ja wir haben
noch vor kurzem tricks von von euch
gesehen auf bild.de und die zuschauer
haben es geliebt jetzt seid ihr
zugeschaltet allerdings jetzt leider aus
einem sehr traurigen grund der tod von
roy horn wie habt ihr es erfahren und
wie geht es euch damit erfahren haben so
hell wie online geschaltet habe es war
irgendwie die erste nachricht auch von
vielen leuten schon per sms kam das 1
mich hat das genau wie werner paul das
gerade gesagt hat sehr getroffen es
waren sozusagen seelenverwandt es ist
eine einzige marke die wir auch zu zweit
auf der bühne steht es hat in den
letzten jahren immer wieder tolle
gespräche vor allem mit gegeben und wir
haben uns einfach nahe gestanden
wir haben sie noch im märz eingeladen zu
unserer schau in münchen gegangen
zweieinhalb tage sozusagen
woher auch durch die cola maßnahmen
kennt worden ist ja mein erstes
autogramm was ich im leben tatsächlich
bekommen habe was von den beiden
und er hat einen hat man einen wirklich
lang einigenden platz in meinem
kinderzimmer
die zehn oder elf gar nicht erst
bekommen eingenommen und es war insofern
für uns immer oder für mich damals quasi
angefangen mit der zauberkunst
immer ein großes vorbild beider
natürlich siegfried und roy letztlich
gehören sie auch zusammen also ich
glaube sie haben beide auch mal gesagt
ohne den jeweils anderen hätten wir das
nie so schaffen können
und ja eine serie in zwei körpern die
beiden und er ist einfach unglaublich
tragisch was 2003 sozusagen diesem
unfall an seinem geburtstag begonnen hat
also jetzt vor
ich weiß nicht mehr genau ins
krankenhaus eingeliefert worden ist von
der woche vor zehn tagen das gehört habe
da hatte ich schon ein mulmiges gefühl
weil durch den stark anzahl bedingt
natürlich schon
trotz seiner unglaublichen kampfeslust
und seinem mut den er immer hatte es war
unglaublich großer kämpfer das ist
eigentlich finde ich auch so für mich
das tragische wir haben damals als als
wir davon erfahren haben dass er krank
sei aber seit ich glaube dass er das
schafft ja der hat so viel in seinem
leben gekämpft und war ja auch immer die
tyczka fans wie ist das geht nicht mit
ihren und also er hat immer seine mit
unfassbar unvorstellbar großer kraft
seine vision aufgelegt sie war da nicht
mal was immer wenn berlin so und
fertigwaren roy noch kirsche auf der
torte draus getan
genau heute immer noch so irgendwie dem
tierischen sondern gedanken sonderweg
weil das war einfach so der uns lehren
großes markenzeichen
[Musik]
dann hört kurz inzwischen was mich noch
sehr interessieren würde ist daran haben
sie den sieg vor den roi das erste mal
treffen getroffen und vor allen dingen
wie magisch war das treffen also ich war
2001 mal in los angeles für ein
austausch und ich bin leider genau den
zwei tagen habe sie erfahren dass die
beiden opfer hatten das war sozusagen
mein erster hautnah dich dann kontakt
wurde sie gesehen zu haben und wir waren
dann später noch mal zusammen
wir müssen unbedingt noch mal hin aber
es war im prinzip dann schon leider nach
deren offiziellen karriereende durch den
unfall bedingt im jahr 2005 das heißt
wir haben die show tatsächlich lesen
gesehen und wir haben sigrid angetroffen
mann war das letzte mal 2015 glaube ich
im ceasars palace haben wir uns
getroffen
es gibt einen schönen und regen
austausch auch nach wie vor haben viele
seiner tricks hier bei uns in unserer
ecke hatte ich eben auch nochmal in der
hand einem halben steht
wir freuen uns dass es euch gibt war
einfach ja immer ein toller austausch
irgendwie und ich bilde mir ein dass er
auf so ein bisschen zwei seelenverwandte
immer vor sich hat und wenn wir
gesprochen haben wir haben jetzt heute
hatte ich noch nicht erreicht aber
außerdem dass wir in den nächsten tagen
irgendwie mal ein telefonat hinbekommen
andreas und christian ehrlich die
ehrlich bürgers herzlichen dank für den
moment und für die schönen erinnerung
dankeschön